a poco de conocerse la noticia
comenzaron a llegar a esta esquina del
barrio de san telmo en la ciudad de
buenos aires- ofrendas florales para
despedir a joaquín salvador lavado quino
justo en este banco donde están
representados los personajes de su
máxima creación la tira más falda una
tira que hizo reír pero también
reflexionar a generaciones de argentinos
de hispanoparlantes y también de
aquellos que pudieron acceder a la obra
a través de traducciones que no falleció
este miércoles 30 de septiembre un día
después de que mafalda hubiera cumplido
56 años entre los homenajes la provincia
de mendoza de donde era originario
decretó duelo provincial tras el
fallecimiento del creador del humorista
gráfico de la historia artista joaquín
salvador lavado